ah yes Hellboy certainly the most
popular superhero in gaming as of the
month of October 2023 everyone's
favorite love crafty and Antichrist
turned easygoing Paranormal Investigator
hasn't had many foray into the world of
gaming but there's certainly been enough
that he's left his Mark today we're
going to take you through all of
hellboy's appearances in games and show
you the good the bad and ugly of Mike
mola's signature creation translated
through the lens of interactive gameplay
strike up your matches to preserve the
flavor work The Kinks out of your stone
sculpted carpal tunnel ridden god-given
illegal boxing glove get ready to hear a
lot of ah
[Music]
crap Hellboy you got eyes on any of
those cursed artifacts oh yeah I have
eyes on one of these
[Music]
stiffs you know I'm feeling a bit stiff
right
[Music]
now aha it appears you're Afflicted with
tankus controlas the ancient curse of
stifled movement found in many evil
[Music]
residences
I guess you can't sidestep this one a
[Music]
red a Hellboy resident evil clone is a
pitch that sounds awesome on paper the
comics are chalk full of creepy settings
like ancient castles cemeteries and
Villages I can easily see a game that
has you exploring these kinds of
environments solving puzzles Gathering
ancient artifacts for key items and
reading diaries that flesh out the
folklore of whatever evil you're trying
to dispel Hellboy Asylum Seeker
originally dogs of the night on PC 3
years earlier takes a shot at this
concept is it as cool as it sounds or is
it another clumsy mess that pales in
comparison to the king of the
genre Asylum Seeker opens with an old
man giving bprd agents some Exposition
about the evil will be trying to rid the
residents of he explains that there is
an ancient evil known as the noaw canis
also known as dogs of the night waiting
for someone to open a portal on the
night of an eclipse so they can invade
Earth twin brothers who have somehow
cheated death oppose each other one
protecting Earth from the dogs of the
night and the other allying himself with
them we then cut to a cemetery where one
of the agents is investigating the area
and gets ambushed by a creature from the
Shadows now I had to watch that cut
scene like three times to figure out
what the hell the old man was saying cuz
the audio mixing is terrible there are
Parts where the music completely drowns
the dialogue and I had to just sort of
place together what the old man was
saying using context clues before the
game starts we get this little intro
card with Mike magnola art which is
awesome the game has broken up into
episodes and each episode has One of
These intro cards magnola has one of the
most recognizable art styles in the
industry and it was a good call finding
a place for it in this game Hellboy and
Sarah show up at the cemetery 72 hours
after the agent's disappearance his name
is Peter by the way and there he to find
out what went down I think Hellboy looks
pretty good here I'm a sucker for low
poly PS1 Graphics they're easily my
favorite retro video game aesthetic and
I love that Indie Games have kept this
graphic style alive after all these
years so I'm being a little biased here
however I do wish he had a few more
layers of clothing here no shaming but
seeing Hellboy walk around in what I
imagine to be a pretty chilly Cemetery
in just short shorts looks super silly
he's like that one friend that insists
on wearing basketball shorts in the dead
of winter and is all like you guys are
cold I don't get cold so the Resident
Evil essential game mechanics are here
you got tank controls fixed camera
angles and a loading screen every time
you go through a door except they're all
executed just badly I'm no stranger to
tank controls I'm well initiated with
them and I actually quite enjoy them but
controlling HP can be frustrating at
times because pushing forward on the
analog stick will make him take this big
step forward which doesn't sound like a
big deal but whenever I was trying to
position myself in front of an
interactable element in the environment
I found myself wrestling with the
controls as I tried to position Hellboy
at just the right spot you can lightly
push the analog stick forward to make
him walk instead but that just doesn't
feel intuitive I wish and get ready for
the first of many Resident Evil
comparisons you could just toggle
between running and walking with the
push of a button by the time this game
came out developers started implementing
actual 3D modeled environments into
games with fixed camera angles which
does allow for the camera to pan around
follow the player and overall be more
Dynamic but I think it was a missed
opportunity to not go with the
pre-rendered backgrounds approach for
one these backgrounds age like fine wine
look at these backgrounds from Resident
Evil I know I know sorry I also think
this would have been a more conceivable
way of implementing magnola signature
art style of using heavy shadows and
distinct color palettes that really make
Hellboy pop from the background after
all pre-rendered backgrounds are
essentially paintings broken up into
different layers to give the illusion of
3D space magnola could have done some
himself or at least be a consultant by
the way that's not to say the
environments here suck they they don't
they carry that appropriate Moody
atmosphere that should be present in all
things hell booy Hellboy Comics just
have such a distinct look that I feel
are essential for any medium we may find
them in this game having 3D modeled
environments also allows for the camera
to change perspectives and into a
traditional third person camera angle
whenever we enter a combat scenario and
boy let me tell you the combat in this
game is easily the worst aspect this is
a big caveat when making a Resident Evil
style Hellboy game Hellboy is a big
Action Hero sort of guy I mean just look
at his design he was practically Born to
Fight big monsters so going the action
beat him up Style game is the obvious
route but I appreciate the guys at cryo
Studios going in the direction that they
did for this game it's really inspired
in hindsight even with all its faults
but you do lose out on getting any
satisfying combat the combat here is
kind of nonexistent really like yeah you
can punch enemies with your right hand
of Doom but there aren't any mechanics
here for me to play around with combat
boils down to you positioning yourself
in front of the monster and holding down
the square button no joke this strategy
can be applied to just about any enemy
you encounter and oh my God enemies take
so long to die it took me two minutes to
take down just two zombies what a slog
you do get to use the Good Samaritan
which I think I shot total of three
times I ended up stocking up ammo in
case I came across tough enemies for no
reason because just punching enemies and
stun locking them pretty much guarantees
your survival and that's the thing
there's no survival element in this game
when fixed camera angles and tank
control bearing video games have some
sort of combat element it's not really
about how good combat mechanics feel
it's more about making the decision of
do I spend my resources on this enemy to
clear path or can I circumvent vent them
and save my resources for a bigger
threat you know like resi that
philosophy is not found in Asylum Seeker
at all combat encounters go one of two
ways guarantee your Victory by standing
in place in front of an enemy and
mindlessly holding down the square
button or easily run by them without
giving it a second thought look at how I
easily avoid these three-legged penis
monsters I actually think it would have
been pretty bold of this game to
completely ditch any combat mechanics
and instead treat each enemy encounter
like a puzzle you know like a pointand
click adventure game where it's about
using the right item or interacting with
something in the environment to take the
enemy down there's actually one instance
in this game where that's the case
there's this big bug monster that's
infesting the place with smaller bugs
attacking her directly doesn't do
anything but you'll notice that whenever
you clear a room of her gross little bug
spawns she'll birth more of them when
she's squeezing these little guys out of
her bung hole she'll lift her head
exposing a hidden Nook in the room you
got to use this this brief window to
slip underneath her and get to this spot
to activate an explosive that'll take
her out now this didn't exactly blow my
socks off but I did think it was a step
in the right direction and if these
instances got more and more complex as
the game went on I think it would have
been far more engaging than the brain
dead combat we have here let's catch up
with the story after investigating the
cemetery for a bit and solving some
simple puzzles we find Peter dead we
fight a topless owl lady and get
separated from Sarah I ran around in
circles in this area for way longer than
I should have because it's so dark I
couldn't tell that there was a torch in
this wall for me to use my lighter on
after fighting these ghouls with [__]
T1000 hook arms we come across the first
major puzzle we got to balance out these
pedestals using rocks of different
shapes and sizes seems easy enough uh
okay you go there that one
here and this one
here h didn't
work okay how about you here that one
there and this one
here
no okay I got this i got this okay that
one here this one there and you
here that one there this one there and
this one here [__] one eternity later
okay this one there that stone here and
that one there ha first
try the puzzles in this game were
unexpectedly amusing and were never
obscure or frustrating I was able to
solve all of them without the help of a
guide which I consider to be a big plus
some of them were hilarious with how
ludicrous the solution to them was like
this one part where a creepy Skelly guy
won't let you into a room because you're
not a monk so Hellboy just [__]
Pockets a decapitated monk's head and
holds it in front of his face when he
confronts the guy again and it works I
was expecting the puzzles in this game
to take themselves more seriously
revolving around folklore riddles and
the like that you have to decipher or
play some keys on a piano that
correspond to a poem but no sometimes
you just got to feed a hungry kid some
chicken after reaching the Asylum we
sought after we yeat a crazy one-armed
nurse out of window get bared on and
discover one of the wizard twin brothers
living in the walls he explains that
every 666 years an eclipse happens that
brings our realm the closest it possibly
can to Hell the last time his evil twin
brother attempted to open a portal to
Hell during the eclipse he stopped them
with the help of an amulet with that
amulet nowhere to be found in the
present the wizard sends us on an
excellent adventure 666 years in the
past one thing that really hinders this
game's pacing is this boring ass loading
screen it pops up every time you go
through a door and in a game where
you're constantly backtracking and
sometimes getting turned around and lost
for a bit these loading screen times
really add up and I found myself
glancing at my phone and getting
distracted in a game like Silent Hill
loading into a new room doesn't take
more than 2 or 3 seconds so it's not
really an issue Resident Evil takes a
bit longer but it plays this short cut
scene where we shift into the player
characters POV as they creep up to the
door and swing it open it's a really
effective technique that builds tension
and makes this transition into a new
room feel seamless this Bland ass
loading screen in Hellboy feels like
you're hitting a 4ot high speed bump and
is really outdated when other games of
this style were being craftier about
this sort of thing so after solving a
few more puzzles and fighting this
nightmare fuel of a boss we recover the
amulet and go back to the
future I freaking love this bit of
Hellboy falling flat on his face like
it's a Family Guy gag this following
sewer section puts Evil Dead hell to the
king's head Edge maze to shame every
Corridor looks exactly the same I never
felt the need for a map in this game
except for this section I absolutely had
to look one up on game facts it's damn
near impossible to navigate these sewers
since there are hardly any landmarks or
any type of indicator letting you know
where you are eventually we make it to
hell where Sarah is being held captive
and fight one of the most disappointing
Final Bosses I've ever experienced
because you don't really fight it all
you do is run into four of the same
zombies we've encountered before just
colored red this time and punch them to
death to raise these platforms and reach
Sarah with the day saved we eat [__] one
last
time and brush off the fact that we'll
have to deal with the same problem in
another 666 years thankfully I won't be
around for that Hellboy Asylum Seeker is
unfortunately a bad video game debut for
the Dark Horse icon apart from a few
amusing puzzles there's really not a
whole lot to enjoy here the story leaves
a lot to be desired which was the most
heartbreaking aspect with how many great
stories there are to pull from the
comics or be inspired by I do have to
highlight hellboy's voice actor David
gasman this is the first time Hellboy
was given a voice four years before
Pearlman became the one everyone thinks
of and gasman absolutely knocks it out
of the park he sounds a lot more like
the voice I hear in my head when reading
Hellboy Comics I don't like this
Pearlman brings a lot more Charisma and
humor to the character whereas gasman
Nails the man a few words and schlubby
Vibe of big red in the comics so this is
definitely the highlight of the game
perhaps going in a more combat focused
direction for a Hellboy game will Faire
better given you know Big Rock
Hand
[Music]
all right that takes care of the first
artifact Abe any idea what the next one
is AE one moment I'm making
[Music]
progress find yourself someone else
that's talking about the Hellboy Java
game in 2023 we're doing great things
here simply titled Hellboy here we have
a fairly competent 2D platformer that
kind of reminds me of the old Prince of
Persia games it features an original
story of Hellboy getting stuck in some
sort of spiritual world ruled by a
Native American Shaman along the way
you'll fight Nazis frog monsters
werewolves and even a handful of bosses
and I've got to be honest I was kind of
surprised by the number of combat
options given here as you'd expect you
can punch enemies with your right hand
of Doom or just shoot them with the Good
Samaritan but you can also use the
actual environment to your advantage by
picking up crates to toss at enemies
pushing rocks down a slope to stop
oncoming bad guys and shooting
stalactites to bring them down upon
unsuspecting foes take enough hits and
hellboy's right hand of Doom will ignite
allowing you to do extra damage there
are also these Shooting Gallery sections
that do a pretty good job of adding a
bit of variety to what would otherwise
be a very Bare Bones game now I can't
say I loved my time with the Hellboy
Java game but you know it did its thing
I beat hellboy's own high score in the
survival mode oh come on man 5 seconds
and you're supposed to be the guy to
bring forth
Armageddon Hellboy 2 the Golden Army
also got a mobile game called Tooth
Fairy Terror and it's based on this one
moment right here you tap away using the
Good Samaritan as you blast through
swarms of tooth fairies to build up a
high score shaking your iPhone reload
your gun and that's just about all the
game has going for it really not the
most exciting use of the Hellboy
property if we're being honest
[Music]
gentlemen this one's worse than we
thought you'll have to hurry and here I
was thinking I could take my sweet time
maybe go for a
nap Lobster how you doing on your end
I've spotted the L I'll show them what
for you know Lobster I appreciate you
coming on this assignment with me and
all big fan but uh how do you plan on
destroying the artifact I mean I have
this thing big old right-handed Doom
supposed to be the K Armageddon or
something folks tell me I'm anama but
it's just too much for me man I
tried you just shot the thing didn't
you I just shot the
thing revity is
appreciated seeing as how the execution
of a resident evil clone was lacking I
think it made more sense sense for them
to get a standard beat him up route for
the next Hellboy game since those were
all the rage back then and he's a unique
character that loves to clobber things
unfortunately though Hellboy the science
of evil is a big load of hellboy's
favorite
word oh crap you know in my memory PS3
games look just as photorealistic as
games today then I play them again and
see they barely look A Step Above PS2
games well not all the expensive ones
but for a game like this these Graphics
have that dark and muddy texture that's
so emblematic of the time period games
were just more grimy back then I do like
the flashback level set in Japan though
it's a nice break from the rest of the
game's cave likee atmosphere oh dear God
that jump please don't make me platform
like this it's like the game starts to
stutter when I jump because it can't
handle the camera suddenly jerking up
into the air that quickly and then
coming back down just as fast the longer
you hold down the jump button the more
you'll kind of
float I guess it's not the the worst
I've ever seen but it feels pretty
clumsy I like how we've settled on a
good middle ground between Mike mola's
geometric and stylized depiction of
Hellboy and the realistic version he's
got that cartoonishly square chin but
still doesn't look completely out of
place in real life aside from being a
literal devil Injustice 2's Hellboy
model may have taken some notes from
this one a few years later although
here's a dumb nitpick I think his right
hand of Doom is too
big much like the David Harbor version
It's just so out of proportion with his
normal hand that it doesn't feel like
another appendage but instead a big
glove he's holding the right hand of
Doom is definitely bigger and batter but
he doesn't have to be a lopsided left
for dead Boomer freak scale it back so
he looks like it's actually part of his
body you know this game doesn't really
have any puzzles to speak of the best
you have are special alternate ammo
types that unlock things for you so you
just shoot them to progress sometimes
you need to go hunt for a Candlestick or
a torch to burn these Red Vines because
Twizzlers are are better then you just
get a Special ammo type that can do it
for you and uh yeah that's it you just
shoot stuff it's a bit lazy and doesn't
really work well enough to offer a
reprieve from the combat this ain't no
Pandora's Temple that's for sure like
any hacking slash beat him up spectacle
fighter brawler God of War Devil May Cry
clone you got a light attack and a
strong attack and all the fun little
button mashy combos there in however
unlike God of War this game's combat
didn't have an instant pickup and play
factor for me it took a little bit of
time to get used to because Hellboy
stands out in this genre full of agile
blade wielding characters by being slow
and deliberate in his move set which I
think fits the character well he's not a
ninja he's a bulking brawler that
smashes with his big Club fist because
of his natural endowment he favors his
right hand a lot in combat making him a
little asymmetrical with the type of
punches he throws HB doesn't really have
the range of a Blades of chaos
chainsword thingy he has to be right up
on enemies to do the most damage so the
game forces you to push yourself in
close for grappling enemies and combos
there's a big emphasis on grabbing
foreign objects in fights too like
tombstones barrels fence posts trees
ladders boxes and other stuff he can
hold like a sword in that way that he
always does Hellboy just isn't Hellboy
unless he's resting a giant sword on his
shoulder and then breaking it two
seconds later because he's a clumsy and
brutish combatant on paper this all
sounds well and good but I just don't
love the execution of the combat being
so heavy and solid should make you feel
like you pack more of a punch but
instead it just feels like playing as a
moderately strong guy with weights in
his shoes I don't get the satisfying
crunch of Destruction under my stone
fist that I so desperately desire the
enemies is just feel like slippery
little bars of soap that I'm just
chasing around desperately trying to
catch they're so fast and small and Hell
Boy is a walking brick he's also brick
colored the combat also feels unfin
finished it's just the same two
mechanics of bashing things and then
shooting them with your slow ass gun but
there's no way to combine the two in any
kind of combo system shooting completely
breaks the flow of your hand-to-hand
combat and punching prevents you from
being able to aim with any certainty
it's one or the other but I'd like to be
able to mix and match the approach
there's also no defensive options at all
because Hellboy can't block or evade so
you're just so if anyone tries to hit
you one of the bosses does a grab attack
oh [__] it's [__]
cigor uh for those of you who don't know
what the word cigor stands for it's
short for cybernetic
[Music]
gorilla it's so bizarre to not have a
block or Parry or anything because the
R1 button is right there and it has no
function at all it's completely
unassigned for the whole game weird
there's also no upgrades or skill trees
or any of that honestly it's kind of
refreshing because I personally hate
overly complex skill trees but it hurts
this game because there's no sense of
progression I don't feel any stronger in
the last level than I do in the first
I'm still just using the same basic
attacks and combos nothing has changed
in any way for this genre of game that's
just really weird all of these types of
games have upgrades even goddamn
Spiderman friender foe has unlockable
moves in a point system I really feel
like this game isn't finished
the slowness of movement also makes it
harder to deal with enemies that have
any ranged attacks like the machine gun
notans and the gas masks they can get
off so many shots in the time it takes
for you to slowly waddle over to them
when fighting most enemies in the later
half of the game they drunkenly slumped
to the ground and ragged all out after a
few punches then get back up to keep
tormenting you so the more efficient
move is to hit them with a weapon to
stun them then do a finisher move combat
also just feels way more satisfi Ying
with a weapon in hand because you have
better reach and you can hurt crowds of
enemies more easily so put these two
together and it just makes using your
fist seem kind of pointless almost like
you should go out of your way to not do
it because it's so harmless then they
throw enemies at you that can't be
grabbed or killed with a finisher in the
desert level and I just start to lose
patience with it either by shooting
enemies repeatedly which seems to have
basically no effect on them or bullying
this one individual that kept getting
back up for hours
hey bat dad I didn't hear no
B enemies being this spongy in a game
like this isn't fun it's just tedious
I'm punching the same guy for like a
full 60 seconds each every encounter and
it just brings the pacing to a dead halt
turns out the enemies in the desert
level can only be beat with these orange
crystals in the environment or these
swords or turning the crystals into an
ammo type again no fists hand to hand
melee combat use useless in this hand
toand melee combat game [__] this game's
also got a real problem with stuff
randomly not working sometimes you'll
pull the trigger and your gun won't fire
sometimes you hit the button to grab an
enemy and it just doesn't work sometimes
you try to switch ammo types and it just
doesn't do it I also had problems with
enemies clipping out of bounds where I
couldn't fight them forcing me to
restart the encounter enemies can also
get stuck on the environment and I have
to backtrack to go find them so I can
get through the door and that's
embarrassing for everyone involved it's
not the most consistent or stable game
but it works just well enough that I was
still able to beat it barely there's a
really shitty part in the fourth level
where you need to drop enemies into a
pit to progress but you can't throw them
into it they need to just tumble in as a
ragd doll after being knocked down here
look I actually tested it throwing it
does not count knocking them in like
this do does I have no idea why this is
like this there's not much that can be
said for bosses this game has barely any
the first is a fight with cigor that
really took me back to the olden days of
gaming when you were supposed to just
figure [__] out by yourself turns out
this boss is invincible and the only way
to beat him is to tear down the support
beams on every floor of the building to
collapse the ceiling on him if this game
was made today there'd be several
intrusive hints on the screen flat out
telling me what to do or multiple
friendly NPCs standing off to the side
shouting the solution at me in the form
of a question so I could still feel like
it was my idea it's nice to not have
your handheld but there was Zero
indication that this was the intended
strategy and it took me forever to
figure it out so game design sucked then
and it sucks now for completely opposite
reasons it's crazy there's never been a
single good video game in history except
for Pac-Man World on PS1 next boss is
the witch lady and you just throw things
at her and that's it sucks big worm
thing you throw rocks at it then shoot a
laser at it's annoying because it's hard
to throw stuff at the worm when your
auto Target keeps wanting to hit the
soldiers on the ground instead
sucks [__] [__] this final boss
obviously Ron Pearlman plays Red in the
game but this also has a two-player
co-op mode to make things less of a
tedious drag and player two can be Liz
Sherman or Abe sapen with their actors
from the film reprising their roles
between this and the animated movies
these three were just really dedicated
to these characters at the time and I
admire that the co-op mode is the same
as most games any bad game is a little
bit more fun with a friend the TDM is
reduced when you can punch every enemy
at twice the speed though player two is
a bit less useful since they can't grab
heavier objects and enemies or break
down doors so they're at player one's
Mercy Liz doesn't even get a gun so she
can't help with any of the gun-based
puzzles some of Blair and Doug Jones
provide incredibly small rolls with just
like tiny bits of generic dialogue that
are hard to hear over the combat and are
just like commenting on random things in
the game play I played for like 30
minutes and heard Abe say one line Liz
Sherman can't even technically be in
these flashback levels because she'd be
like a year old or not born yet this is
the definition of tacked on there was no
thought that went into the co-op mode
you might be wondering why I haven't
talked about it yet but this game
doesn't exactly have a strong story
really any kind of story it's full of
cutcenes of NPC skeletons with the same
voice just making vague Illusions to
some kind of like dark back story but
never actually saying anything definite
or interesting I almost don't know why
they bothered getting Ron Pearlman for
this if all he's going to do is throw
out dead pan quips and dry humor he
doesn't interact with the bprd or any of
the other major Hellboy characters
there's nothing for him to really bounce
off of or interact with he's just kind
of talking to himself the whole game you
just go from place to place cracking
wise at monsters but nothing's really
happening there's no plot I guess at
best you find out that all of this was
being orchestrated by this metal head
guy to create a big monster with dark
magic but like the story doesn't really
matter until like the last like 5
minutes and then you just kill the thing
that he made easy paycheck for Mr
Pearlman I guess even still it's nice to
have him here because he fits the
character so well well his speech in the
desert is just a delight I love this
scene now someone not an idiot but
someone might see this is just a new
cautionary metaphor merging with the old
one the encroaching industrial world and
all that oh yeah that's another thing
you remember the X-Men Origins Wolverine
game that would shift perspective
between two time periods 10 years apart
to give variety between the levels and
demonstrate the connection between
Wolverine's past and his present this
there's nothing like that for some
reason this just has random flashback
levels to different time periods twice
and then never again one 20 years ago
another 40 years ago they don't really
have any reason to be there and they
barely tie into the main Game's plot at
all I think they just wanted the game to
not exclusively be in a stuffy European
Village how come these Nazis are using
the new Twitter logo on their un oh
final boss is garbage then the game just
abruptly stops because they didn't
finish it that's it that that's the
ending did you know you can't get 100%
completion in this game's achievements
because the last two chapters were going
to be released as DLC and they canceled
it after the game's critical and
financial failure Bruce Campbell was
going to be Lobster Johnson in the DLC
his name's still in the credits [__]
what a kick in the nuts that would have
been awesome despite the game's failings
I really wish I lik this one more
because I thought it looked awesome when
I I was a kid and I just never got a
chance to play it until like this month
and
then you know how do you [__] up a God
of War clone with Hellboy that should
have been so easy but they did I wish it
was better I wish the combat felt more
crunchy I wish it had a better art
style thanks for
nothing Hellboy the signs of evil also
got a PSP version that somehow manages
to be better than the main console
version It's essentially the same
experience but an overall a bridge
version of its Big Brother counterpart
and it does the game favors levels are
shorter which gives the game a Brisk
Pace combat is simpler with combos being
more limited and the ammunition type
system being completely absent this more
streamlined approach puts the game in
this safe area that makes the game
unremarkable but also not a pain in the
ass to get through un unfortunately
there isn't any voice acting to be found
which sucks because perlman's
performance is probably one of the few
highlights of the other version and
cutscenes are replaced by these 2D
animatics that's always a good way for
these comic book licensed games to
capture some of the source material
style I think the graphics age far
better here they're not as detailed as
the main console versions but the bright
colors and smooth textures avoid that
muddy ugly look that so many games of
this generation suffer from this version
also supports Co-op play whereas the 360
and PS3 version lets you play the entire
story mode in Co-op the PSP version has
separate levels and changes the camera
angle that's akin to something like
X-Men Legends if you're looking to play
Hellboy the science of evil I'd say go
with the PSP version you can beat it in
a few hours and again it's it's a better
experience than the main console
version Fighters approaching the bat
game now we all know I've never been too
keen on injustices story story but if
there's anything to gush about it's
their non-cannon guest characters
sometimes taking a page from Mortal
combat's book and pulling in Punchy
fighty badasses from other franchises
thus we have Ninja Turtles some Mortal
Kombat guys and everyone's favorite Club
fisted Hells spawn as opposed to the
club-footed hells spawn Hellboy has a
great look in this game he's still
blocky and stylized but doesn't look out
of place in this realistic setting first
thing that stands out is how weird it is
that they can't really do asymmetrical
character designs so his fist switches
sides with him to keep from animating
the moves differently depending on what
half of the screen you're on his move
set is appropriately uncomplicated it's
just all different variants of smacking
you with the right hand of Doom or
shooting with the Samaritan pistol he's
not exactly known for having a huge
variety of moves or a big arsenal of
weapons and gadgets he doesn't need all
that most of the time but here it would
have been nice to throw in a little
something else it's fun to see him
chatting it up with characters you'd
never normally see him interact with
like DC heroes Mortal Kombat fighters or
the damn Ninja Turtles the other kings
of Indie
Comics bet that shell comes in handy
against the right hand of Doom you
bet don't worry I won't crack begin if I
had any complaints it's that John
Constantine isn't in this game so they
can't bond over their shared love of
smoking trench codes paranormal
investigation and not giving a
damn
bralhalla is a freeto playay Super Smash
Brothers clone that I absolutely suck at
it features a ton of guest characters
from Street Fighter Ben 10 avatar The
Last Airbender and a bunch more Hellboy
was included to coincide with the
unfortunate release of the 2019 reboot
as well as other characters from the
movie like nimu guak and Dao Hellboy is
a skin for braw Hall's own character
cross it works perfectly since cross has
these giant gauntlets that can be easily
reskinned as hellboy's right hand of
Doom I always have a hard time playing
these kinds of party fighting games
because I can't keep track of where I am
in the midst of chaos between four
Fighters so I'll just check out the PVE
hard mode that also happened to be
included in the Hellboy update
yeah look at me
go these hallways are like a maze yeah
no kidding I'm getting turned around
here
I think I hear something something
big oh crap so do
I oh sorry about that Lobster don't
sweat it red I think we're getting close
to the source of the curse it's going to
take everything we got to Snuff it
out oh don't
worry that came prepared you're the only
only guy I know who I'm certain is not
compensating with that thing
thanks if anything that sword is on the
small side for
him there's that son of a
[__] all right you foul Wretched Spawn
of hell hey uh sorry prepare to feel the
wrath of the
claw all right this one has the best art
style of all them no contest it just
looks like magnola Art In Motion I
haven't seen this since the amazing
screw on head between this and high-i
rush I think cell-shaded Brawlers are
making a comeback I truly miss games
using a stylized graphical look to
replicate comic Styles like Tales
Walking Dead Or Ultimate Spider-Man
basing their models on Mark baggley art
this game perfectly captures the
specificity of the Hellboy art style the
rounded shapes that have little
imperfect angular corners on them the
stylized Anatomy and geometric
proportions of mola's pencils I can't
get over it even the simple single
colored backgrounds that clash with the
shadows and dark colors the characters
create a really unique contrast just
like the panels it's all here I remember
seeing a Hellboy fan animation on
Twitter some odd years ago it perfectly
translated mola's art style into 3D and
I thought like I'm certain many others
did man this would be perfect for an
animated movie or a video game then
shortly after that Upstream arcade
released west of dead a Rog likee
isometric shooter with an art style very
much inspired by Mike magnola not only
that but Ron Pearlman also voices the
player character it seemed like the
stars were aligning for an inevitable
Hellboy game in this art style and they
indeed were Upstream arcade is back once
again with a Rog likee Hellboy web of
word this game tells an original story
that's very much in line with what we
come to expect from Hellboy comics
the bprd has picked up some psychic
spikes scattered around the earth that
when decoded reveal coordinates pointing
to an old abandoned house in Argentina
in the house we discover a chamber that
drops us to a separate Dimension known
as the word it houses creepy Living
statues wear rabbits and Godlike
entities that speak in riddles it's all
appropriately Hellboy with its overall
tone and the way the story is delivered
something in the word is causing spikes
in the normal world and it's up to
Hellboy to dive in over and over again
until we find out what Shahara
sharazad sha
Charizard I'm definitely not one of
those guys that insists one actor who is
good in a role was born to play the
character and can never be recast Ron
Pearlman nailed it with Hellboy
obviously but I'm open to other actors
voicing him and playing him in the
movies so Lance reic getting cast for
this role immediately made me more
excited for this game because he was
always one of my favorite actors he's
the guy who got one over on Eric Andre
on his own
show need a new desk he's earned the
respect of John Wick and by God he was a
[__] fantastic Albert Wesker despite
the show he was in being wal to wall
doooo safe for his performance his take
on Hellboy stands out to me because he's
not just doing an impression of
pearlman's version like most guys do the
personality shines through as the same
calm and composed wise cracking devil we
know love but he just reads the lines in
his own way and makes it his own it's
one of the biggest highlights of this
game for me as long as there are no
balloon animals lady we're good rest in
power Lance you are a goddamn Legend
much like Upstream arcade's last game
web of word is a Rog likee so you can
expect the usual elements found in the
genre like procedurally generated levels
randomized items and perade death huge
asteris on that perade death though
because I found this to be one of the
the most casual Rog likes I've ever
played the game is really generous with
this checkpoint system given its genre
to the point where at times it feels
like it's structured almost like a
traditional linear action game for the
majority of its runtime the deeper you
get into the story the more the game
starts to feel like an actual Rog like
eventually asking you to do a straight
run from the first level all the way to
the final boss without dying I like that
the game contextualizes why Hellboy
needs to clear multiple levels in one go
there's a part with the PRD agents take
bets on how many tries it will take
Hellboy to do a complete run I thought
that was clever Hellboy stories often
deal with pocket dimensions and other
Fantastical Realms so making sense of
the concept of runs in Rog likee games
within the context of a Hellboy story
can be easily done I don't really play
Rog likes in fact I uh I didn't really
even know what a rogue like was I
actually had to ask Diego about it but
for some reason anytime I've ever heard
the term Rue Rog like it sent me into a
blind rage where I wanted to kill
someone and I don't know why like I hear
someone go like man I I'd like a Rog
like in this in this franchise Like a
Star Wars Rog like and then then I hear
that and then I just want to just start
swinging you know I just want to bite
someone's jugular and just start
drinking their blood does that make
sense
hey X yeah it's it's Diego
I'm yeah I'm almost done editing the
reviews
um you all right man we have a rack tag
group of bprd agents to hang out with in
the hub World known as The Butterfly
House in between trips to the word
there's team leader tatler she's a No
Nonsense hard ass who's a little shaky
when it comes to trusting Hellboy she's
a woman of Faith so hellboy's demon
looking ass makes her nervous to say the
least there's the obligatory team
psychic lucky voiced by none other than
Wolverine himself turned out there was a
fundamental design flaw poor guy never
stood a chance foul mouth Tech expert
Alman the conversations with this guy
always trip me out a bit because the way
he stands almost looks like he's teing
so I thought the game was glitching out
on me and finally there's our two
folklore experts mads and Bens that you
can talk to to get a better
understanding of all the supernatural
phenomena you come across I've said it a
ton of times before but I love Hub
worlds and comic book games it's the
perfect opportunity to flesh out the
World by having all sorts of
conversations with The Supporting Cast
as well as offering a bit of a cozy
breather in between the action and web
of word did not disappoint in that
regard this is mostly where the story
will progress every time you return from
a run in the word you'll have a new
conversation unlocked that advances the
plot
besides catching up with the team you
can also read any diary entries you've
collected examine artifacts and level up
your gear stats and weapons leveling up
Hellboy and Your Arsenal is another way
this game is very casual in its
roguelike elements all of the upgrades
you make to your weapons gear and big
red himself are permanent I don't have a
whole lot of experience with this genre
but the Rog likes I have played are not
as generous as this one dying will
usually have your character start as a
blank slate and it's all about how lucky
you are in any given run when it comes
to coming across upgrades so even if you
aren't doing so hot in subsequent runs
in web of word your odds are only going
to get better sooner rather than later
because you'll be stocking up on the
currency that goes towards upgrades this
game stands in a place that makes it
seem like it was a little shyed to fully
embrace the Rog likee genre and I know
there's a term Rogue light to describe
games that aren't as hardcore of an
experience but I'd hesitate to even call
it that on one hand this game be more on
on the Casual side avoids alienating
players that may just be Hellboy fans
and are looking to check out the latest
video game based on the character
without having their teeth kicked in on
the other hand my right hand of Doom one
the game Left Me yearning for a
significant challenge leading up to this
game's release I played West of dead for
a couple days you know to sort of get
into the mood I had a lot of fun with
that game I think it hits the sweet spot
for me in regards to difficulty I always
felt challenged but it was never
frustrating I never knew what to expect
with each new run which made the game
really exciting I hit a few snags with
Hellboy early on but that was just me
getting used to picking up on enemy
patterns once I picked up on the most
effective techniques I was clearing
rooms in less than 10 seconds I do wish
the game offered a higher difficulty
setting even the modifiers you unlock in
the end game didn't do much for me that
being said hitting a groove of dodging
powering and slamming enemies into stone
pillars makes you feel like a total B
badass combat in this game has a
surprising amount of depth and finally
feels satisfying combat feedback is
tricky because it's a combination of
Animation sound design camera motion
controller vibration sometimes and
visual cues to make it really feel like
what you're doing is effectively
damaging the opponent science of evil
makes it feel like you're fighting paper
bags full of mashed potatoes under water
web of word feels like you're a stone
fisted devil bashing monsters to death
with your super strength they nailed the
responsiveness in this game's fighting
mechanics I like how Punchy combat feels
and how it manages to feel satisfying
despite not having a whole lot of
mechanics no doubt because of how
responsive the controls are and how
heavy attacks are accentuated with comic
Booky visual effects but the focus on 1V
one encounters sometimes feels like a
detriment because the smaller Cannon F
enemies are pretty much pointless
they're not a threat and they explode
once you beat up the main big dude dude
in the room you you can go pretty much
the whole game ignoring them while the
levels nail the Aesthetics found in the
comics with simple color palettes and
Moody atmosphere and you do have
different biomes to get through each
with their own theme and unique enemies
like an underwater town with crustation
monsters a spooky forest with rotting
beasts and a ramshackle Subway with a
giant man bats the change in scenery is
great and all but you'll quickly notice
that these are all pretty much laid out
identically just with a different Cod of
paint you walk down a hallway enter a
room usually one with a clearing in the
Middle with a few pillars laid out and
an elevator portion that you can reach
by walking up a ramp there's not much
else to do in between combat encounters
besides looking for extra rooms that
offer Buffs and health pickups sometimes
you'll encounter these purple booby
traps that are of no consequence you'd
have to be an imbecile to fall for one
of
these most of the time they come in the
form of these floating balls that don't
even move so you can easily walk around
them or these brief bursts of fire that
you just have to wait a few seconds to
pass they're more of a minor
inconvenience than anything else I did
like the bosses because for the most
part it did feel like I was fighting a
genuine tougher enemy their attack
patterns are a bit trickier and they
obviously have a bigger health bar and
do more damage sometimes I feel like
bosses in AAA games are more about
putting the spectacle up front rather
than having a formidable foe to go Mano
Amano with like I'm just picking up on
simple patterns while I wait for the
next prompt to trigger a big fancy cut
scene taking down bosses and Hellboy
felt satisfying even with all that being
said I feel like there's something
missing in the presentation I just feel
like I want a Hellboy game with a bigger
emphasis on story because those Comics
are so steeped in lore and paranormal
investigation stuff but these games come
in and just want to focus on hitting
monsters let me do some detective stuff
I don't know anything to break up all
the gameplay of just fighting science of
evil was just taking you to random
locations with little to no connection
and this is at least more coherent than
that but so much of this story is told
through Exposition and these stiff
conversations back at base and not
really shown through the game playay
plus the way these are structured gives
you kind of this awkward like waiting
for the guy to say his next line pause
between dialogue when I touch things
this little box Whispers secretos were
anything useful so far not yet but it is
a big house
I will say though this game looks really
good for something on such a tight
budget you always know a game doesn't
have much money when their cut scenes
are doing like this like motion comic
thing instead of like full motion video
but somehow I just kind of get over it
here because it looks like a Hellboy
comic so much that I just completely
forget while it may not be the deepest
game in most aspects web of word is a
lowbudget title going for as low as 20
bucks depending when and where you get
it which was kind of refreshing in the
midst of massive games that seem to come
out every other week I may not recommend
it for people that are looking for a
challenging Rog like but I would
recommend it for Hellboy fans that want
a game that authentically captures the
aesthetic and Vibes of the books as well
as to hear an absolutely badass take on
Hellboy from Lance
reic
that was weird word it's impolite to
correct people son no I was agreeing
with you oh okay well done gentlemen
this is a cause for celebration rotten
eggs anyone I'm thinking
Seafood hey check it out Red
Lobster
[Music]
ow